c'est beau la catastrophe
vous pensez c'est pas en arriver là
n'a pas le choix on se sent puni
on est vraiment on est vraiment énervé
on veut juste travailler et on peut pas
[Musique]
surtout pour mes employés quoi
même si à du chômage partiel c'est pas
un salaire des serveurs puisqu'il est le
pourboire
ils font plus d'heures forcément du
travail mais c'est plus compliqué là on
n'est pas forcément sous contrat les cd
ils ont été difficiles à trouver après
le premier confinement on n'a pas de
sécurité
j'ai même pas l'âge d'avoir le rsa j'ai
plus de droits au chômage parce qu'ils
sont épuisés pendant la première
fermeture
sincèrement je ne sais pas exactement
comment ça va se passer nous pareil des
patois on a quand même des loyers
assumer les fournisseurs à payer là
beaucoup de plaies c'est vraiment
compliqué quand on nous dit de fermer
bon moi je vais quand même un peu restée
ouverte on reste lorsque j'ai la
livraison et l'emporter mais si on me
dit de fermer totalement je pense que je
serais pas capable parce que finalement
c'est on n'a pas le choix c'est son
travail soit on ferme totalement ferme
vraiment pour demander la clé sous la
porte tout simplement
[Musique]